yes finally somebody's sticking up for
white people killing black people we
didn't want to leave you hanging with no
clips so here's just some general
Insanity of the day every time a black
man is killed by either authorities or
vigilantes in like in the Amed Arbury
case what uh right- Wingers do is did
you know that back in seventh grade he
was once tardy and I we heard that in
eighth grade he was smoking marijuana he
was evil and had it coming did you know
George Floyd might have stolen 20 whole
dollars oh my God these black people
they're so evil did you did you know
that Trayvon Martin uh it was it was
caught in school maybe smoking pot and
that's why Zimmerman had to murder him
in Cold Blood that he had it coming he
had it coming so I can understand if
conservatives and right wiers have done
that and so you're just frustrated and
don't want to hear it but I'm not doing
that it's but it's in the Almond Arbury
case and the George FL case you're
taking the most extreme cases with the
most clear racism with the most most
clear murders and you're trying to
Nuance it and and what I'm telling you
Tim and what has made me uncomfortable
in the past about you which is what I
was trying to get past is that that EXT
attracts a huge right-wing audience
because they want somebody to excuse the
death of Ahmed Arbury and George Floyd
and when you seem to excuse it with your
Nuance then they go yes finally somebody
sticking off for white people killing
black people come on don't tell me there
aren't people in your audience that
think that there's tons of people who
think
that